you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
you know you don't need 140 you know 135
you may need 115 or something like that
and
and but you do need discipline i advise
students
as much as possible look for the job
that you would take if you didn't need a
job
i mean you know don't sleep walk through
life something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out and
find somebody else
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best warren
buffett and my take on his top 10 rules
for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one have discipline
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
you know well you don't need 140 you
know 135 you may need 115 or something
like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business you don't have to swing at
anything you can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait
for that one time in a month or six
months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price
where you like the people running the
business and then you swing and you only
need a few swings in your lifetime
rule number two embrace failure how do
you deal with failure and what's your
advice to young entrepreneurs
like me in this case especially with
regards to failure and how to approach
it yeah well
if if you fail you really do dust
yourself off and
you know get right back in i mean you're
going to fail at some things
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out
uh you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced i mean and you know
that's a very big decision
to have turn out badly but
i think if you study almost everybody
and
read read kay's book you know personal
history and you'll
everybody fails at some things i mean
you know particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and just
knowing about whatever it may be
businesses
uh but you know it it is not fatal
i mean if you're healthy and you live in
this particular living in this country
there's gonna be there's gonna be an
opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was
when i got out of the university of
nebraska you know and i remember you
know
i went to chicago to get interviewed
this is when you traveled on the train
and so i spent 10 hours going there and
this fellow looked at me and
about 10 minutes he said you know forget
it belle
and now i got to go back on the train 10
hours and think what am i going to tell
my dad
well i'm going to tell my dad i mean my
dad always told me i could do anything
and everything now i've just got just
gotten turned down uh you know
but it turned out that one of the best
things ever happened to me because then
i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact it probably
even affected who i married because i
took a one-year course at columbia and
said two years at harvard and she might
have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually it's turned into a success
i mean it it
the world isn't over you know if you
have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean they're just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but
but the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're
bright and you know you've got decades
ahead of you
you know if something goes wrong if you
find yourself working for the wrong
employer and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out
and find somebody else rule number three
focus on your
inner scorecard i got
an awful lot of good advice from my dad
and and he didn't he didn't lay it on me
i mean he just
you know you you picked it up from him
but there was never any of this you know
do this do that
uh type of thing at all but but i think
he really
taught me that it's more important uh in
terms of what's on your inner score card
than your outer score card i mean some
people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what
what the world's going to think of this
or that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're going to going to have
a pretty happy life and i think the
people that strive too much for the
outer
score card sometimes find it it's a
little hollow when they get all through
rule number four read biographies i
should mention one thing about reading
uh it was at the library here at
columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than any other
uh student i i lived there practically
but you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
uh because of uh of that librarian
directing me
to some other book and then following
through on that
it's the chance i i i read about
one-fifth the pace the bill does but i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it's just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people that have been excited
to see them so extraordinary the lessons
and the you know the discouragements
they face just everything about it so i
did
you can't get enough of reading also if
you want to have more self belief and
more self confidence i have designed a
free training program just for you
or every day for the next 254 days i'll
send you
an email with an unlisted video to help
you boost your confidence
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
and so i want you to build the habit of
self belief and self confidence
it's 100 free the link to join is in the
description below
investing in yourself is the best thing
you can do anything that improves your
own talents like nobody can take it away
from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
come worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
it's important to associate with people
that are
better than yourself they made us all
these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things rule
number five think
long term how do you decide what you
invest your time and money in
yeah well i i i like to find
businesses that have good economics now
what what are good economics well good
economics are a business that has
some kind of a moat around it that
makes its product or its service or its
location or something
a little more desirable than to the
customer than any other sort of
comparable product
uh you know the number one candy bar in
the last 30 or 40 years has been
snickers
people don't fool around with different
candy bars they fool around with
different
length dresses they fool around you know
with all kinds of things but they don't
fool around with candy bars
because they figure you know they're
going to go in and lay out 50 cents or
whatever it is and put it in their mouth
and they're not going to for 50 cents
and putting in your mouth i mean you're
not going to say i'll
i'll put in i'll lay out 45 cents and
put something else in my mouth so
you find that very stable and we like
businesses
that we think we can figure out where
they're going to be in 10 or 15 years
i don't know where the information
technology businesses are going to be in
10 or 15 years i know where snickers
bars are going to be in 10 or 15 years
they're going to be selling just about
this you know the way they do now
i know where wrigley's gum is going to
be in 10 or 15 years be there's not
going to be a lot of innovation
in in in chewing gum uh the and people
the internet's not going to cause people
to quit chewing gum either i mean at
least
i mean gates may think so but i don't
think so but uh
it's it's predictability
regarding the sustainability of a
competitive advantage some something
special about a product
rule number six work on your attitude
you both have several managers working
under you so i was wondering what are
some steps that a new entrant into the
job market can take to
accelerate their journey towards an
upper level management position
yeah well one thing i will tell you that
i didn't realize when i was
getting out of school is how much the
unusual person
will jump out at you i mean you know
and it isn't because they got 200 iqs or
anything like that it's really because
of just
how they behave you know what they bring
the energy they bring the commitment
they bring the
quality of how they do things how they
treat the people around them all kinds
of things but
you will jump out much more than you
might anticipate
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do
is whether you like it or not get very
comfortable it may take a while with
public speaking for example i mean that
that's a an asset that will last you
50 or 60 years and it's a liability if
you don't like doing it or uncomfortable
doing it that also will last you 50 or
60 years and it's a necessary skill
but a lot of the skills are just human
skills if you get the best out of people
around you
that's a rare talent and it it doesn't
it doesn't correlate with iq it
correlates with a
you know an attitude and uh toward the
world and toward other people and
it's a talent that if you work at early
and you're really conscious about it
you know you don't have to show up other
people you know you have to be smart in
there or anything
you want to bring out the best in them
it will pay huge dividends
rule number seven don't sleepwalk
through life
if you were to do it all over again
you're in our shoes
what industry would that be in where
would you start your own business today
i'd do the same thing yeah i mean
for one thing i'd be a failure to
anything else probably
no i mean i have had i had fun when i
was in my 20s my 30s now i'm 86 and i'm
having fun and so
i i advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleepwalk through
life and don't don't say
it's all going to be great you know i'll
do this and i'll do that and you know
i'm just
marking time to get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not
it it's not a good idea yeah
[Laughter]
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain it
guess what i'm talking about
now it it you just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it rule
number eight get ahead of the game
it is always being ahead of the game
rather than getting behind the game it's
saving a little no matter how you do it
i mean i
delivered papers i worked at pennies i
sold golf balls i had a pinball machine
round i did a lot of things
that enabled me to accumulate about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school
uh ten thousand doesn't go as far now as
it did then but it
having anything so that you're ahead of
the game and not getting behind the game
is enormously important i mean just you
know if you're going to run a 100
100 yard dash against a bunch of people
in life
if you can figure it out so that when
the gun goes off you're 10 or 15 yards
ahead
instead of 10 or 15 yards behind it's
going to make an enormous difference in
how that race comes out so
uh having having some net
resources doesn't make much difference
whether they're in stocks or bonds in my
view but
and not having debt when that gun goes
off when you get out of school
uh is a huge plus over being behind the
game and uh
you know it may come from delivering a
paper out in the morning it may come
from part-time work someplace but
but put aside a few dollars for yourself
but uh
so that when the time comes and you
enter
you enter the workforce uh you're ahead
of the game and not behind and then once
you get there don't get behind by buying
a whole lot of things that
you figure you're going to pay for some
day while you're paying 20 interest in
between
rule number nine choose who you
associate with
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person
by far in that respect is your spouse i
can't overemphasize how important that
is and you're right
the friends you have uh they will form
you as you go
through life and uh uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like them
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun there we go touting
pretty nice hi can you imagine that i
mean this is
this is the way to spend your time i
think this is better than a mattress i
sleep
i wouldn't i wouldn't fool around with
computers while i could be in this
position
can you remember buying your first first
mattress well
i didn't do very much of the purchasing
in in our family uh
i can't recall ever buying anything
actually
check this man's credit and see if he's
good
[Music]
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an action plan for what
you're gonna do
you increase it from 35 to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan
publicly that jumps to 95 chance of
following through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you is there a meaningful distinction to
be drawn between
making money out of investment and
making money out of speculation it's
always a bet isn't it it's always a
gamble no it isn't a gamble it there is
a real distinction now basically
it it's subjective but an investment
attitude you look to the
asset itself to produce the return so if
i buy a farm
and i expect it to produce eighty
dollars an acre for me
in terms of its revenue from corn and
soybeans and it cost me six hundred
dollars
i'm looking at the i'm looking at the
return from the farm itself i'm not
looking at the price of the farm every
day or every week or every year
on the other hand if i buy a stock and i
hope it goes up next week to me that's
pure speculation
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there